[Music]
how did a real-life cowboy go from rodeo
shows to appearing in midnight texas how
did that same actor land on just about
every western and quasi-western movie
and television show for the last 20
years let's dive into the long and
varied career of fourie j smith
there's a reason why the wise rugged
lloyd pierce on yellowstone imbues his
scenes with such an air of realism as it
turns out the actor behind the longtime
dutton employee for e.j smith is a
real-life cowboy with decades of
experience under his large buckled belt
that experience served him well as both
a stuntman and an actor and throughout
his decades-long career in show business
smith has been back in the saddle more
times than one could count this perhaps
is why the charismatic and occasionally
mysterious lloyd pierce looks so
familiar to viewers beginning in the
late 1980s the actor found himself
starring in several television movies tv
series and films and in each one managed
to prove that as a performer he was no
one trick pony no room for outcasts like
us in the bunk house
by 1993 40j smith had several off-screen
and minor roles under his belt he was
mostly known for his work as a stuntman
in rambo 3 when he took on the role of
pony deal in writer kevin jarre's
tombstone the film told the story of
gunslingers and occasional lawmen wyatt
earp and doc holliday's involvement in
the infamous 1881 shootout at the ok
corral in tombstone arizona the movie's
cast was stacked with a-listers but even
among the superstars smith managed to
make an impression with future casting
directors at least though smith's role
in the film was as a non-speaking
ensemble member of the criminal clanton
gang the film's success helped the
experienced stuntman showcase his stage
skills
four years after his role as a
rambunctious cowboy and tombstone 4 aj
smith starred alongside javier bartom
rosie perez and james gandolfini in
director alex de iglesia's critically
acclaimed dark comedy perdita durango
strutting onto the scene smith's
armendars attempts to negotiate with a
fellow criminal before being killed in a
shootout although the scene is
relatively short it allowed smith to
fully embrace and embody a character
with some semblance of a backstory the
film's cult status helped the already
prolific and in-demand additional crew
cowboy flex his acting chops the year
prior smith had starred in a short scene
in the made for tv movie ruby gene and
joe wherein he delivered a few drunken
lines at a birthday party before getting
punched in the face by tom selleck still
it was hardly as big an on-screen moment
for the actor as his shootout in perdita
durango
though for aj smith's screen time in
duncan tucker's oscar-nominated
transamerica was short his dialogue in
the scene acts as a catalyst for a
critical moment for the film's
protagonists in the movie a religious
conservative woman named dabri who is
saving up for sex reassignment surgery
is compelled by her therapist to track
down the son she unknowingly fathered
while still in college brie heads to new
york to track down her son but since she
is unable to explain the true nature of
her relationship to the street hustler
teen she pretends to be a christian
caseworker the two embark on a
cross-country journey back to la and
along the way stop at a roadside market
in arizona called sami's wigwam smith
plays sammy who assumes the angsty teen
is the woman's child and when toby
swears it breathe smith's character
chastises him you watch your mouth
around your mouth she is not my mother
she's not anyone's mother she's not even
a real woman it's an important moment in
developing the character's relationship
and vindicates bree's fears and her
motivations for lying to toby while
illustrating that the two very much
already come off as a parenting child
smith's success following his role in
transamerica is proof that sometimes
it's more about quality than quantity
when it comes to screen time
by 2017 for ej smith had established
himself as the man to call when casting
directors were looking for a real-life
wrangler and horseman who also knew how
to deliver a line in 2013 he provided
his animal wrangler skills to the crew
of two guns in 2016 he worked with
future yellowstone creator taylor
sheridan as an animal wrangler on the
oscar-nominated heller high water while
one would be hard-pressed to recognize
smith in either film he had a more
visible role in the breaking bad
spin-off better call saul in the season
3 episode mabel smith stars as the
junkyard owner of 5j's auto salvage who
loans mics and tools in space to work
in 2018 for ej smith lent his
charismatic western aesthetic to nbc's
midnight texas
the town of midnight is a safe place for
outsiders who fit the category mainly
based on their supernatural
characteristics among that cast of
outsiders is former were tiger and now
cured reverend emilio sheehan in the
episode to witch hell and back viewers
learn the origin of sheen's identity and
watch as he struggles to come to terms
with his past smith appears in the
flashback as the real reverend emilio
sheehan a priest and cowboy who was
killed by the transformed were tiger
years ago when the weretiger transformed
into his human self again he took on the
priest's identity racked with guilt and
determined to atone smith's real-life
experience clearly helps him get across
the rugged realism of the characters he
plays that seems to be true whether he's
being attacked by a were tiger or doing
the dudn's dirty work on yellowstone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]